moment to moment moment to moment I
don't wish it on anyone this this moment
is has been overwhelming for all of us
first and foremost to the families that
were lost
obviously their lives have been turned
upside down to our brother Colby and his
family Vanessa and Natalia Bianca Capri
send our prayers and condolences my
family went through in the midst of all
of this something I couldn't have
imagined that makes for insane
I spent time talking to my kids for
about 45 minutes as this was all
happening and our colleague Jared
Greenberg brought to me the news that
morning and he asked my texts if I had
heard of the story and I I said oh the
shoes that look Kobe gave LeBron and
Kobe passed him last night and he said
no he said this is here you need to sit
down and he texted me the article and I
just I went into full-blown denial and
fortunately you know one of my my
daughter's greatest fears is finding out
that a parent or one of her parents
would be lost through social media
instead of from a you know a loved one
or a family member and and you know she
fortunately called me and we just were
talking and crying about the news of
Kobe and and my son and then we started
you know so we were talking I was
talking to my kids just trying to spend
the time with them and then the phone
just started going off and I'm thinking
to myself everybody wants to talk about
Kobe and and I right now I want to be
with my kids and my family and then all
of a sudden my best friend King Rice was
a basketball coach you know King Kenny
not Carolyn are you
yeah okay he walked off the court at
Iona and somebody's apparently told them
that I may have been on the helicopter
and he he started calling something
seeing Kings number you know repeatedly
going and going and going and I think
he's worried about me so I said I'm
gonna talk to my best friend and I
answered it and I said hey man this is
crazy about Colby and he just was
bawling and I started crying and he was
like you're alive and I'm thinking well
yeah like what do you mean and he and it
was in that moment that my phone just
started going and my mom and my sister
and my brother and and so look this is
this has been this has been a lot to
process for all of us quite frankly were
blessed to have had the time we had with
Colby a city is mourning a families
mourning where we're all morning and and
I'm I don't you know I'm glad that's
over with but it was hard to deal with
because it shook a lot of people in my
life
finding out as I was on my way to LAX to
travel started getting text messages
please don't tell me this is Kobe and
again I'm thinking about the night
before still so I'm confused as to why
somebody's texting me just saying that
and that's it so then I get a call from
my fiancee and I can hear in her voice
something's not right so now my heart
starts to really speed up then my
brother takes me with the first meteor
story attached to the message and I lost
it luckily I was a passenger in the
vehicle so now I had to explain to my
guy Duran who's with me tonight like
what just happened he loses it my kids
start calling me and asking me to come
back home do not go to the airport and
get on the airplane they're devastated
and I get back home before I can get in
front of a television just as a family
we're all hugging each other and saying
we love each other because you never
know if that's gonna be the last moment
my mom calls me which took this tool
another level of pain my mom calls me
she lives in Little Rock she tells me
Rick's the rumor is that Rick was there
too and that broke
that broke my heart already thinking
about Kobe learning about Rick and then
when I got home and started watching CNN
I find out it's where it happened which
is three exits from my house
and then I knew exactly where he was on
his way to him was then before I even
heard on the news you know it and I knew
where he was going and it was possible
your sons and everybody here and your
family playing these AAU tournaments
there you know exactly what was going
and it was possible that his more family
with him when there's Chiana or Vanessa
or that like I was I was done and I just
that's what I don't want to get lost in
the pain like as I try to figure out the
right things to focus on to help us get
through it is what he was doing for
young people and young girls in women
he's not here anymore
but somehow we have to continue to find
the strength to do more for other people
than we would do for ourselves like you
said earlier Kenny like eating out to
spend the time he was spending doing all
of these things for young people with a
young girl of course for his own
daughter but
I just hate dead
this had to happen in order for us to
appreciate the full version of Kobe
Bryant
not just athletic greatness but like the
full version of Hui and appreciate each
other